♪ ("PULCINELLA" BY JEAN-MICHAEL
PANUNZIO PLAYS) ♪
I'll take a mocha.
And I'll have a vanilla...
One of the vanilla
bullshit things.
You know, you--
whatever you wanna--
some vanilla bullshit
latte capa-thing, you know,
whatever you got, I don't care.
-Okay?
-SERVER: You got it.
What? What's the problem?
I don't really like this uh...
-(STAMMERS) What?
-This new Larry.
What's the matter?
Just too enthusiastic and...
-Oh, really?
-I miss the old Larry.
-Oh, do you?
-Yeah.
Hey, there's Jeremy.
Larry, Larry, great,
glad I caught up to you.
Housekeeper said
you'd be down here.
I wanna talk
to you real quick, uh...
Let me-- let me take a guess.
-(CHUCKLES) Well alright.
-Aright can I take a guess?
Yeah. Sure, sure.
You don't want me to write
the letter of recommendation.
-Wow, yeah, well jeez.
-Holy, what a...
That's a load off my mind,
I'll tell ya,
-I'm willing to uh--
-It's a shame though,
it's a shame because
I wrote some really
laudatory things
about your work with the...
-the geometric shapes,
-I don't think that's--
-triangles and the trapezoids
and all that.
-Thanks.
Yeah, there's a little more
to it than that.
-Well I don't know about that
-But I mean, you know,
-they're very compelling figures
-I really wanted you
to write it.
-with triangles, square...
-Thanks, yeah, well, thank you.
Hey, you take care of yourself.
-Alright, you too. Yeah.
-Okay, maybe some other time.
I'm available for any,
any kind of favor that you need.
Okay, thanks a lot. Buh-bye now.
Coffee on me!
Ladies and gentleman,
free coffee and donuts
and Danish and bagels.
Anything you want,
on me, I got it!
Everybody, come on.
Come on up, get some coffee!
That's right, go ahead.
Enjoy yourself.
Attaway! That's it.
-Don't be shy!
-Hi, I'll have two coffees.
Thank you very much, thank you.
Come on, people.
Everything on me.
This is very good,
by the way, thank you!
-This the café latte?
-SERVER: Mm-hmm.
What is that, milk?
-Milk and coffee?
-SERVER: Milk and coffee, yeah.
Milk and coffee,
who would've thought?
-Milk and coffee, oh my god!
-You know, we can go now,
if you don't mind.
-What a, what a drink!
-Do you want to take off?
It's milk and coffee,
-mixed together!
-Let's do that.
You've gotta go there, sit down,
have a donut, have a bagel!
♪ (MUSIC CUTS) ♪